ci siamo allontanati un po di più e
bella notizia di testori
io oggi sono timoroso e io ti mangio se
devo fare un nuovo challenge slime vi
ricordate la sua legge tre colori di
colla clime siccome ho ordinato tanti tv
glitter come potete vedere che
bellissima all'arcobaleno l'arcobaleno
co più colori il sindaco deve scegliere
o poi usato persino facciamola tre
colori di colla slime challenge però con
i glitter ho pensato però forse tra i
colori di glitter sono troppo pochi
quindi magari facciamo lì dentro ma 55
colore di glee star chelsea quindi con
l'altro salesi dovremmo bendarsi e uno
alla volta dovremo prendere un colore di
glitter alla fine avremo cinque colori
di bitter diversi e dovremo metterli
nello slime lo slide sarà trasparente
con la colla trasparente così potremo
vedere bene i colori dei clipper
altrimenti con il bianco quello con la
bianca non si vedono bene evidentemente
non lo conosciamo lo slide il verde qua
dovete proprio vedere se becco il verde
anche oggi utili prende tutte le
corrette rivedetevi 5 saranno tutti in
questi qui alla fine del video come
sempre vi metterà un po i sondaggi
dovrete votare subito
parole come marenzoni in base alla
bellezza dello stile volete vedere altri
challenge is live ha lasciato un bel
live su questo video e fateci sapere nei
commenti che apre challenger volete
vedere con spiate se l'è pure nei
commenti
siete pronti mettetevi comodi patatine
col coro the caldo cioccolata subito
scartare e cerci se non sociale sono
tappati le orecchie troppo del bando
perché no di rumori strani mischiare
bere tutti i colori ma non sbagliarmi ma
dai così può usare i pazienti paolo
franco
allora sono tutti mischiati a buy
ok perché vista in posizionando la mano
tutti nuova ai misteriosi ricordati i
rischi di non avere 12
allora perché il mio primo questo una
fase così vicina il verde allora ho
preso un celeste bellissimo e l'inizio
con un celeste il mio primo colore
staccate
io però deve rendere tutti i colori
simili possibile rimane tutta di un
dolore lancinante
elezioni allora 5 dobbiamo prendere vi
posso prendere 75 a nome di tutti dai ok
tali a bergamo mi sa che aprendo un
altro allora adesso paga un prezzo al
rosso pensavo fosse il verde la coperta
dove risposto il peccato più grave non
solo mondo il flusso delle professioni
posso natale il colore doppio tubo che
ha ragione però detto tra via trento via
a vabbè così rosso quindi ha ragione
cosa celesti più rozzo ammette st
ricordare quello che sono
sto mischiando è fatta di sicura questo
ho cercato un'altra celeste 9 grigio
argento e grigio e argento se conosceva
zigoela che colore steccati esca allora
o scusa o altri colori sul rosso così
posso farlo tutto rosso sulla tv cult
oppure il verde perché così con il verde
il rosso posso fare lo slime di natale
si ti sei fissato che vuoi fare con la
pesca
[Applauso]
io prendo io anche se ce ne sono altri
quattro e così fosse diverso perché non
sembra l'album rosso e verde vista
proprio che gira natalizia il live di
natale posso fare forse aggiungiamo una
pallina dopo no sono glitter questo
challenge
dobbiamo prendere dei piccoli regali da
montreux del the bubble osorio dritte
bari valeri io faccio il tema oceano
mare o sirenetta quindi mi fanno ridere
bluceleste magari di questo nuovo e
cambiò la rosa e viola sds bird faranno
le alghe nel mare le alpi nel mare le
altre lo guarda come l'ho sistemato
bellissimo ambiente come guarda non
portare non sto guardando vado
questo mare viola il bellissimo portata
ha preso il viola ma prima ho detto che
mi andava bene il viola perché parola
una sorta di mare e con viola dai festa
questo mi ha tirato proprio celeste che
come voi e non c'entra niente contro
slide di natale o no e celesta che spar
nel cielo dell'albero di natale cioè
sopra l'albero di natale c'è il cielo
quindi il celeste rosa per bene con
l'intento è quindi questi sono i miei
colori dello slide di natale adesso
stato offerto a me parte dell'organico
di tutto dai che tutto il verde ci sta
bene nel top line no
ci sta bene quale scegliere siccome
rimettervi lontano ti amo o la robiola
quindi ho due viola un se letta e un
argento diciamo che col tema mare ci
siamo proprio allontanato in italia non
cambiare il tema ma non so che tema
scrivete voi nei commenti
io spero di prendere oro o argento
perché sta bene non è tipo le stelle si
chiama stelle filanti le decorazioni che
si mettono sul sull'albero di natale
fino legear la liberty quindi color oro
o argento e oro argento andate bene
oppure teme sono altra variazione del
rosso del verde marrone dai è bellissimo
e ora no perché ne abbiamo già 4
mettiamo gli appare torino secondo me
sono più belli quelli di vitale mi sono
buttato riversare un colore più chiaro
adesso vorrei io spero che mi capiti ma
io non so che devo fare perché la
maggior parte in viola sirena
una mischia d'accordo no
falsa tutto questo è l'ultimo scelte
difficile ci siamo allontanati ancor di
più questo che cosa è vero e glitter
d'ora no è un verde chiarissimo lo
vedete
ma no verde chiaro guarda quasi 2
ottobre per questo secondo me verde
chiaro e questo è un giallo bertolino
secondo voi non c entra niente slide di
natale dai buy e che colore è questo è
un eroe acqua verde avere la meglio su
cosa capita tombe questo vero che
l'acqua è affetto per il mio è un di
natale fatti perché non è perfetto così
lei a perfetto perché facciamo il
laghetto vicino all'albero di natale
quindi sappiamo ma è invece presente
abbiamo il rosso delle palline
dell'albero di natale il verde
dell'albero di natale il blu del cielo
dell'albero vita
il dorato che ora sono l'oro giallo già
l'este fa parte delle stelle ed
operazioni del corso di capitale
dell'angola e dello style di nathan è
questo qui che è il colore del laghetto
che sta vicino all'albero di natale è
perché dello slide di natale ma tutti in
casa che collabora in un laghetto no il
laghetto dell'albero di natale io lo
slide anche voi avete il laghetto là
dell'oceano ma ho solo un celeste chiaro
che non lo so poi o grigio argentato un
po oscuro
poi due viola e un d'ora pd che vive
secondo voi che tema può essere un cazzo
di piatti che dobbiamo vivere
sì perché faccio il celeste e il cielo
il argentato sono le stelle viola e
altro viola sono le varie galassie e
giallo altre stelle
vediamo ora che andiamo a mischiati come
silano allora iniziamo con i primi
perché abbiamo pescato il primo per me
erano questi ce le stia un po
ecco qua il colore è stupendo vediamo
innanzitutto come diventa con questo
tour frattempo puoi mettere i tuoi primi
tiri con le quali erano i primi che
pesca in rosso vai anche se io voglio un
partito dal cielo blu navy e nei nervi e
il michelin è già bellissimo ancora come
brilla mai ma come brillerà dopo forse
ne ho messo troppo
io invece ha fatto con il rosso e vado
delicatamente cielo stellato bellissimo
io voglio mischiare tutti dopo posto che
allora il secondo che ho pescato
era questo giusto questo spese d argento
scuro
ok andiamo a mettere l'argento oscuro
che farà le nostre altre stelline
vediamo un po che strano re un celeste
un po più scuro si vedano le stelline
argentate il mio secondo colore invece
se non sbaglio era il verde che vado ad
aggiungere qua quindi propri e nathalie
si sa è questo siccome il verde che deve
rappresentare l'alberone a un pochino di
più fuori il mio terzo colore non mi
conoscerà questo questo tutti i ricordi
no è tutto viola domani o lo 0 2
questo ok allora ho messo un po di viola
e facciamo che rappresenta la galassia
la casa da sealine kalex
[Musica]
il mio terzo colore se non sbaglio da
questo blu che rappresenta il chievo
temo sia dell'altro il cielo dell'albero
di natale dello sliding di natale il
cielo rappresenta anche una bella parte
di questo live quindi mettiamo un bel po
misura molto brillanti le lettere con
questo tipo di scene prese a mare come
diventa mischiare nostro prendo il mio
prossimo colorerà questo viola un po più
chiaro
[Musica]
meno male c'era questo colore un po più
chiaro perché erano quasi tutti scuri i
miei colori
ok sta dando un tocco di colore in più
si vede un po di più questo viola e tu
il mio quarto colore invece
rappresentare le stelle con il dorato le
stelle del cielo dell'albero di natale
dello sliding natale e mettiamo un po di
tiro di stelle qui le mettiamo
direttamente sul cielo piccolo grazie
ragazzi mercato può più stare
poi il mio ultimo colore era questo
bertolino che vitali dice che giallo
mario bertoli
dite voi i commenti secondo voi piccolo
re questo comunque andiamo a metterlo
almeno da un tocco di colore anche
questo stona stellare ragazzi vediamo un
po
chissà poi come diventa attivato
professor critter a tutti decisamente
sembra un po un craxi che venissimo
molto quello dell'euro sembra invece il
mio ultimo colore è il verde acqua che
cos'è il presente e albania immaginario
rappresenta il laghetto che sta vicino
all'albero di natale dello sliding di
natale quindi aspettiamo qui il laghetto
oled e qualche bello laghetto il
piccolino
ricapitolando abbiamo diverte
dell'albero di natale il rosso dalle
palle dell'albero di natale il blu del
cielo della giura di natale le stelle
nel cielo dell'albero di natale dello
slang dentale e il laghetto che sta
vicino all'albero di natale lo slime
dentale teorico ok ora mischiarle
vediamo un po come diventa se rimane
natalizio o se diventa allora diciamo a
mischiare il rosso con il verde
wow mi sa che diventasse forse conta la
maledizione del verde visto molte cadute
di te va bene c'è deve rappresentare
l'albero di melangolo inverte bellissimo
guarda che colori delicati che proprio
dei colori natalizi guardando abbiate
wow
l'indomani è abbastanza natalizio sa che
si vede in fuori per riflesso del ros
dell'albero di natale dai anche se il
verde non è male i miei mezzi
celeste e colori bellissima ora andiamo
ad attivarli e poi vediamo cos'è il più
bello tra i quali news live galaxy e
super glitterato biamonte e il sito una
sorta di sicuro perché non c'era bisogno
di colorante una sorta di blu scuro
guardate un fuoco anche l'inter sembra
quello di cielo stellato
[Musica]
poi ovviamente come sapete con la sua la
trasparenza bisogna aspettare un paio di
giorni prima che si chiariscono infatti
ora tutte le bolle saranno ancora più
bello perché non sarà opaco ma sarà
trasparente
allora mi faccio vedere meglio il
glitter con tutti i riflessi color e
quindi il mio galaxy cosa ne pensate
scrivete nei commenti mostrano molto da
dirsi però spesso e questo non essermene
ecco a voi il mio slime di natale
a chiederlo e verde dei glitter tutti
sberluccicanti rossi blu al coro e
verdolini ed è fantastico
e come diceva nyt ha visto che è appunto
un click ci dovrebbe essere un click
line ma siccome abbiamo appena fatto non
è ancora clear vedete opaco questo
questa meta una cittá sullo slime
rappresenta la neve che sta sull'albero
di natale lo slime di natale che bello
vedere questo è tutta questa parte opaca
che è tutta la neve che poi si
scioglierà la farà diventare lo slime di
natale un clero slime parecchie robello
ora facciamo con le vostre mister quelle
presenti sparsi
guardate come elastico adesso sentiamo
anche i suoni le bolle scoppiano tutto
tutto
faccio più qua wow bellissimo questi
suoni e molla e ci sono anche se non
sono tantissime ma è super bello
guardate che stupendo allora che cosa ne
pensate quale vi piace di più lo slime
di anita onlus live di natale lenti
anita estranei di natale è più bello lo
slum di natale secondo me no
che stai facendo male allora vi lascio
questo da oggi potete votare se vinco io
dalla flai monselice vitale spline
rivelare se volete che vi facciamo
questo challenge
ok mischiano i glitter con i coloranti
lasciate un bel laiche di simile chi
andremo a rifarli e mio luminoso un
problema sterline su cui cliccare
perdere i nostri altri video nostri
challenge slide video divertenti
cliccate su quella che preferite
ciao